shortages 1970s are back well new data
from the bureau of labor statistics
shows that inflation is actually rising
much faster than virtually any economist
in the country predicted overall we
learned today
the year-over-year gain in the consumer
price index is up 4.2
that's the fastest jump in 13 years
since the 2008 meltdown
the rise in what's called the core
consumer price index that excludes
food and energy is the highest in 40
years
since 1981. peter schiff is an economist
and ceo of euro pacific capital he joins
us tonight to explain what this means
peter schiff thanks so much for coming
out what does this mean and should we be
concerned about it
you should be concerned and as i said on
the program last time this is a tax
it is the inflation tax and if you look
at how much the cost of living went up
measured by the cpi in the first four
months of this year
it's two percent so if you triple that
to annualize it
we have consumer prices rising at six
percent
annually but if you look at the monthly
numbers every month
it accelerates so if you extrapolate the
trend of the first four months of this
year
for the entire year you're going to get
a 20 increase in consumer prices
in 2021.
so i mean because our financial system
is a global system
other countries china most notably buy
u.s
treasuries with an expectation of return
if the value of the u.s dollar starts
falling as quickly as
these numbers suggest it is why would
any country
invest in u.s bonds and government bonds
i mean
doesn't this threaten to cause you know
shake-up
well they won't yeah they're going to be
selling u.s treasuries i mean
anybody that can connect these dots is
going to be selling u.s
treasuries and the problem is there's a
lot of us treasuries to be sold
you know and they talk a lot about the
shortage of goods the real problem is
the surplus of money
you know whenever you print a lot of
money right it's always a good shortage
because the federal reserve can print
all the money they want they don't but
they don't print products
to buy with the money so we have all
this money being printed we're not
producing a lot
people are sitting at home cashing
unemployment checks this is a tax
it is an inflation tax abide in tax
whatever you want to call it
but when joe biden says that don't worry
only people that make over 400 000
a year are going to have to pay higher
taxes to fund all these programs
he's lying because every american is
going to pay the inflation tax
and it's going to hit the middle class
and the poor the hardest
so i don't understand since you just
described it in the clearest possible
way
when you print a ton of money the value
of that money falls
it's more money chasing fewer goods
fewer people working to make those goods
of course you're going to wind up where
we are today
with massive disruptions to the labor
market and spiking
inflation why didn't any of the geniuses
making these policies
anticipate this look
even the so-called geniuses at the
federal reserve they keep telling us not
to worry
because according to them it's all
transitory but these are the same guys
that told us not to worry
about the subprime mortgage market
remember early on
ben bernanke said oh don't worry about
subprime it's contained
well now they're saying don't worry
about inflation it's transitory
inflation is as transitory now as
as the subprime market was contained and
this inflation crisis
is not only going to be worse than the
financial crisis it's going to be worse
than the pandemic
because the government's cure is what's
going to kill the economy not the
disease itself
that's right nicely put this is worth
worrying about i think if you print too
much money it's worthless
that is a law of nature peter schiff i
appreciate you coming on tonight i hope
you'll come back
i will my pleasure hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else